this week's videos are sponsored by
manscaped and Shopify more on them after
the reaction
people oh my goodness citizens of the
reject Nation it's me Tara Ericson
and Greg ala are you rhyming or just
saying it in a tone it whole it was a
Vibe is what it was I thought going to
rhyme he did not join in he did not yes
and he did the classic I said my name
yes and he did Dead Pan movie I guess
anding was filling in the blank I'm not
having it you know what he was he was
Pitch Black and that's the movie we are
watching today Pitch Black in his soul
cuz he didn't go with the rhyming with
me Pitch Black we're watching itday
there no Rhymes happen neither of us
have seen it
or done a nope I can't do it I can't
rhyme not today guys sometimes I'm good
at it today I'm not you better leave a
like you better leave a comment for what
just happened here I tried what the hell
happened and also don't forget weird
bring aell that's definitely the
weirdest one ring it a bell ring it a
bell ring it a bell ring it a bell also
thanks to prepper for helping us edit
down these videos we call you super sexy
if you join patreon we get over there
and we're like hey you're super sexy
we'll write you a w about being so sexy
and slap you in the ass slap you in the
ass that didn't rhyme either that's what
he said he said it first say slap on the
ass slap on the
ass we're going right in there cuz if
you join our patreon we're going right
up in there all right we're not afraid
to take risks sexy ones we love you a
lot do you need to update them on
something cuz I'm rocking and I'm
rolling at this you are killing it today
now listen uh we're going to watch Pitch
Black it's got V diesel in it I'm a huge
fan so huge you haven't seen Pitch Black
so huge he's a huge man I'm a huge fan H
that was a rhyme you guys heard it right
here are you talking about that was I
rhymed I said he's a huge man and I'm a
big fan okay you're right I did you did
I wasn't listening he what are you
talking about he wasn't even he's he's
complaining about my rhyming he doesn't
even register it I can't it's a good
first video yeah we should watch the
movie now huh yeah he's so funny we're
ready I'm pretty sure I'm your you can
seriously come with your own cop Gregory
is my only he's my only fan here on the
channel everyone El only fans and then
there's only fan I ter only he is my
only fan everyone else is like she's a
lot she a lot to deal she's a lot she's
loud I'll addit the intro I'll be like I
don't know why I find this woman so
funny I think she's
hilarious o right R okay I didn't know
that oh getting into it
now banana
banana I hope this movie matches your
energy today it's called pitch black
pretty sure it won't except that's the
color of my soul
okay who is that an actual like model
not
CGI looks
real oh my God even the text is in Black
this is like the opening of Space
Balls that looks pretty pretty
awesome this a '90s movie so apparently
okay so there's three of these this a
'90s movie We're watching a movie from
the '90s this is a there's three of them
and I don't know anything about what any
of them were about they say most of your
brain shuts down and cry or sleep I
believe that all but the Primitive side
that V voice Bo has got
me the animal side the survival side no
wonder I'm still awake transporting me
with civilians sounded like 40 40 plus
oh I miss Bleak Sci-Fi movies free
settlers and here's my real problem Mr
John's planning on taking me back to
slam only this time he picked a ghost
Lane what an interesting way to set up
your characters a long time between
stops long time for something to going
wrong also I'm trying to get Vin Diesel
to audiobook me to
sleep so everyone else gets to stay
asleep while he's semia awake not
anymore God his voice was so soothing I
it's so
good oh what a cool POV reveal oh damn
oh
waking and now
[Music]
dead ouch it's my wife every
morning Captain's dead cor shows we at
22 weeks out so gravity was not supposed
to kick in for another 19 why' I fall at
all I love this camera Jitter we're
himring air something took a swipe at us
come on come on just tell me what's
still on the shipping Lan man just show
me all those Stars come on kind of makes
you feel like you're on a boat it's like
not even yeah it's like they're doing a
a floating Vibe
oh I didn't know if you know this but
when you enter back into the atmosphere
you get hot oh really yeah
yeah o we got it hey we got
it wowza this is
intense it's really bright this movie is
a
liar yo these effects are pretty cool
recommend purging
B okay yeah like she had to pull like 17
handles just then I know that makes it
feel realistic when you do it crisis
program s number two in the system
because it shows at least some oxygen
maximum terrain 220 M over a mean
surface Lely Cinder and gipson with some
evaporite deposits you think when they
go to pitch black the the floating will
stop I this is a little nausey
do oh is he like a criminal villain yeah
I think he's like somewh they
transporting okay company says we are
responsible for every single one of
those people fry what we both die out of
sh ability don't you touch that handle
fry pull the 39th handle do it I love
that her name is
fry I'm not going to die for
them lock
doors I us still have 70 seconds to
level this Beast out I love the Old
School production design of this
interior not
secure oh oh what the is happen up
there how is she not sliced in dice
right
now just a few glass particles in her
hair no problem wouldn't she just be
like
burned like oh boy the glass that can
sustain that of heat you apparently
can't cut
her whoa what a weird looking shot what
the hell what are they doing with the
frame this is when they were like we
have an anamorphic lens and we're going
to use it
oh she's for sure dead now right yeah oh
whoa what a wild opening yeah so the
only ones survived were the ones in the
boxes right that's a safe presumption if
she comes out of the dirt I'm going to
be like what which she probably will cuz
she is a '90s actor that worked a lot so
I don't feel like they would kill her
off I hope not the best looking one on
the crew she's very
attractive is he a 902 and0 back in the
day guy I'm not I'm not your guy yeah
I'm not I'm not my guy
either uhoh V Diesel's free but the next
two movies are named after his character
so maybe he's like an
anti-hero
whoa ouch somebody's going to get hurt
one of these days and it going to be
me oh she is alive and fully Well w she
looks amazing yeah she looks great like
she just took a shower so I guess
something went
wrong
oh wow he wait
dead I'm sorry looks like your EP
epidermis wasn't as imp penetrated oh my
God he's alive he's alive he's living
don't touch it don't get out of him no
no no it's too close to his heart
there's some anesty in the Medlock in
the back of the cabin not anymore m not
get out of here I have to kill him now
get out of
here what a weird reaction like this is
we're being weird about this
feel like she's having a very human
response right
now whoa it looks like they shot her on
a bright location then brightened it up
even
more they raised those Shadows they
raise those highlights wow this is what
you get what a weird looking film
interesting May because is a little old
it kind of looks like a concept film
that you'd see on
YouTube yeah you're right a very
expensive one there was talk of a
scouting party looking for other people
but then we saw
this oh that scouting party be dead his
Beast wasn't made to land like this but
I think he did well at least they landed
on a place with oxygen whole bloody
container is upside down it's all it's
all Topsy
to
now that is a neat place to store your
[__] I don't suppose this will help you
at all unfortunately it is not permitted
especially while on hot oh that's him oh
Keith David
yeah now there's something kinky about
the way he's tied up yeah and also what
is that thing in his
[Music]
mouth like the set Department was like
just get me any BDSM stuff you have at
home and let's lay it on
him what no
no whoa how did they do that that was an
awesome shot did do you think he
actually knows how to like dis no you
can't do that you would die that that
was super cool he trained himself to
dislocate his shoulders it looks so real
he was so committed I mean if the man is
gone he's gone why should he bother us
maybe to take what you
got maybe to work your
nerves this guy or maybe it just come
back and sculpt you in your sleep he's
my favorite
character everyone is an arch type but
I'm not used to seeing these Arch types
put
together excuse
me I think you should say
this three sons yo there is something
very odd about the way this movie is
edited yeah what that looks very green
screen we take this as a good sign path
direction from all it's a bit of a bad
sign that's Rick's Direction I thought
you found his restraints over there
towards Sunset which means he went
towards Sunrise do they need ridic they
haven't really explained it that's why
he's like just let him go what happens
if Mr rck spots us first there'll be no
shots oh they got to take him
alive interesting how the tint and the
color of this now it's
blue but why the change oh cuz now we're
in his point of view it's a good
guess trees trees being
water I love how Bleak and serious this
is yet simultaneously cheesy yeah it's
like fun cheesy with this dark aesthetic
I wonder if the coloring is to hide
because it's not real like there's a
green screen back there yeah than that
it looks
real probably get you right here and you
never even hear him coming cuz that's
how good rck is tell me something did
you run away from your parents or did
they run away from you I love that line
okay just to reestablish the plot of
this movie is they're they're hunting
for Ric and they're trying to figure out
where they are and survive yeah I don't
know why they need Ric maybe he's their
like pet killer oh my God is that a
dinosaur I love dinosaurs is this whole
planet
dead oh man if we don't get some
terrible CGI creatures I'm going to be
very
[Music]
disappointed that's a pretty cool like
set right here like what we're looking
at is I like it oh is he just asleep or
hiding he looked like he was asleep his
body language looked like he was passed
out I think we should keep moving what
Owens mean I'm not touching the
handle this dude just oh that was
shot he's going I'm not your
captain he's that close yall don't feel
him there he's the one that stopped the
docking pilot from dumping the main
[Music]
cabin see Owen and the docking p it
being did he just take a piece of her
hair like did she
yes maybe he sees things
differently I'm into it this is one of
the oddest things I've seen in a while
yeah this is really odd and this like
set that they built is pretty awesome
anyone
here okay so it would appear that some
type of creature has annihilated some of
the former inhabitants but then why are
they also all dead all the
creatures Allah abbar this is the source
of the
water hello
MEA love how exasperated that guy
constantly
[Music]
looks it's their own Millennial
Falcon yeah is this the way R I think
this the way Ric sees sees like is he
like okay so he's like oh oh my God I
thought I was the only one who got out
of the crash of life
oh uh it was just somebody else in the
crash Cy I thought it was him I thought
it was to take him alive so you made two
mistakes oh my God H this movie what is
this film I have not quite latched on to
what the toone is I don't know either he
is so relaxed and just hiding in plain
sight like nobody's business
what the oh there's a creature what is
that what what
[Music]
what
dam
it wasn't Ric his blade is unbloodied
oh yeah you're right it is how he sees
okay what did you do to
Z what did you do to damn V diesel
getting his asset this would not happen
to his contracts now so where's the body
well do you want to tell me me about the
sounds I feel like every every cut to a
new scene lapses like 10 to 15 minutes
in time you don't want to talk to me
that's your choice but just so you know
there's a debate right now as to whether
we should just leave you here to die you
mean The Whispers The Whispers I mean
that's how he talks he talks in a
whisper what Whispers the wind's telling
me to go for this sweet spot just to the
left of the spine fourth Lumber down the
abdominal aor it's a metallic taste
human blood but if you cut it with
peppermint snaps that goes away of
course you want to shop me with the
truth now okay so he's some type of He's
Not Human Show Me Your Eyes
Ric you'd have to come a lot closer for
that so he's going to be the he's going
to be the one to help protect them
against these aliens and protect her
heart who's this director there's so
much like style
choices oh
God where the hell can I get eyes like
that got to kill a few people okay I can
do it you got to get sent to a slam
where they tell you you never see
daylight again oh this happened to him
you pay him 20 Menthol cools to do a
surgical shine job on your eyeballs so
you can see you sneaking up on you in
the dark exactly leave what a great way
to get an exposition did I kill Zeke no
he's not in the hole we looked look
deeper he's just a mush of blood this is
how R gets rid of everyone they just all
keep this hole the hole like bye-bye
[Music]
now I don't know why they're not like
well rck go in there show us drag the
body out it's dark in there it'll be
great for your eyes
yeah I really wonder if this director
did music videos before there's so much
like the shot choices yeah you could
tell that I could tell this director
likes a lot of things and is trying to
include a lot of things but there's not
really a succinct tone or Rhythm there's
not like a through line in regards to
style yeah yeah it's kind of a mishmash
kind of all derivative
things they're
Hollow is that a creature behind it
is what is
that whoa it's a land
[Laughter]
octopus oh girl you better get
going they look like starfish octopus is
that the way they see things when when
the camera that anamorphic
Choice
oh that's a huge climb what happened to
the Rope did it break and I wasn't aware
oh
I think she's coming out a different
different side got
it not anymore oh boy I'm in here I'm
[Applause]
inside please can you hear
me come on little boy find the
[Music]
hole
can rck like sense them I feel like he
[Music]
can whoa I heard you fry I heard
you my sake I found his foot I don't
know what the is in there whatever it is
it got Zeke and it nearly got me
oh did they take off the Rope I I just
assumed they took off the Rope yeah why
wouldn't they do that
come on y'all just cut it at this
point good
lord it's a waste of a good Rope though
finally found something worse than me
huh so here's a deal again just like the
time jumps every every scene just a time
Jump as I'm tired of chasing you you
saying you'd cut me loose I'm thinking
you could have died in Crash my
recommendation do me ghost me mother
that's what I would do to you
[Music]
damn Vin Diesel used to know how to
really deliver these lines in a way that
did not sound cheesy you mean right now
delivering I like damn this badass as
hell yeah yeah especially in the
beginning dialogue I was like oh damn
Vin Diesel I If that had to do with
direction or his choice it's great yeah
he's just kind of like you know
yeah do we have a deal want you to
remember this moment
the moment I let you
live yeah man this director loves to
experiment with his
DP the coloring is what's like the most
wild to me from the bright orange to the
blue to the then regularly colored maybe
this is when people started getting
access to computer editing programs and
they were like let's try them
all all right all right my T my are they
act working on getting off this planet I
don't know
honestly they were working on water for
a minute
okay you're missing the party I need to
start saying that on all my
dates missing the party come
on this is it gives me a headache I
don't know why remember that Ghost Rider
2 movie we saw that like crazy one I
feel like it's kind of similar for the
way have odd odd Vibe odd choices nice
of them to leave so much stuff here why'
they leave their ship they didn't leave
their ship they were killed remember
those land squid you had to fight off
yeah lady these people didn't leave come
on who got Zeke got them they're all
dead that's rude rck maybe they had
weight limits you don't know I know you
don't prep your emergency ship unless
it's aing
emergency right I love the kid I love
this copy
[Applause]
cat BS they have a hard time hearing
gunshots but they can hear that kid
screaming I don't want
it hey this is how Batman came to
be that look like a pretty cool effect
what's he trapped in with right
now Jack wait wait
Alie I'm so fascinated about how this
movie kickstarted a franchise and now
it's called pitch plaque it hasn't even
been pitch plaque
yet than do all those little things
become one big thing or are they food
for the big thing oh or maybe it's more
like alien which this movie seems very
much to be aping where they have like
little ones and then big ones yeah
oh that transition I can't that is an
old that what the hell why was that
transition like that it really like I
made the joke of them being like let's
use them all all but I feel like that is
exactly what they're doing these cing
samples are dated last one's 22 years
ago this month okay is there something
special about that car this really does
feel like something you would see on the
Sci-Fi channel oh absolutely at like 1
in the morning that's probably why they
got a A series everyone on the Sci-Fi
channel was like
more
Eclipse uh-huh You're Not Afraid of the
Dark are
you I mean Vin Diesel is the best part
of the movie yeah he really is by and
large look you told me that we could
trust you said that we had a deal John
didn't say we could trust as far as I
can tell he hasn't even lied to us let's
just stick to the deal John he's a
killer and the law says he has to do his
bid there is nothing I can do about that
you hear me oh self
serious slowmo close-ups of that I don't
want
it pull a handle make it the 41st one
strange not doing a run up on the main
drive yet unless he told you the
particulars of my Escape he literally
just didn't you think John is a do right
man you think I could trust him to cut
me loose why what did you
he play a
cool I am worth twice as much alive oh
you didn't know that you're John's and a
cop he's got that nickel slick bad man
he's a bounty hunter don't waste my
time we're not going to turn on each
other no matter how hard you try this
must have been fun to watch it when it
first came out when you would wonder is
Vin Diesel really a bad guy or a good
guy but I think like watching it now
you're like well he's obviously a good
guy ever wonder why John shakes like
that ask him and ask why your crew palow
had to scream so painfully before he
died it's a fair point these are fair
questions he's bringing new info is
johon dying and he needs money that's
why I bring reick back but also how does
that tie to the way the guy screamed so
that when he died I don't know I don't
know oh or also is he a drag at okay
yeah maybe they like performance
enhancers oh my God what are we looking
at what are we
doing oh yeah he's a drug addict so he
puts it in his eyes so you can't tell
not a cop are you I never said was SC
how'd you get on the ship what does the
ship consist of who are the people on
this crew yeah and why are we did we
miss a line cuz I feel like we haven't
talked over any of the important stuff
Owens was already dead his brain just
hadn't caught on to the
fact is there anything else I should
know about you John I'm just a cool
Cowboy
man I'm not your captain it's going to
be her character Arc she's going to uh
realize that she she is a
leader we're getting close to the
eclipse that they showed us on the on
the model
right if we need anything from the crash
ship I suggest we kick on that sandat
solar Clips sand okay yeah alien
creatures I feel like Mad Max watched
this movie and was like there's some
aspects of it we like but we're going to
redo it I feel better I think flip that
because they Cally watch Mad Max first I
know but this one came out before so I'm
like didn't they have they had like the
goggles the kind of car look no no Mad
Max came out with the Mel Gibson ones
first oh [__] you're right never mind
they took yes and then they didn't they
didn't really whoa whoa that's a cool
shot that looks pretty awesome surpris
you're um human wise responding with
adverse effects to being so close to
these things right like how are they not
yeah how is their bodies and blood and
brain not being affected they're
superhuman symbolic for his
[Music]
balls it's getting so dark it's getting
pitch black up in here
almost wow that's a lot of them holy
this is like demonic now like flying
[Music]
whoa this's some stranger things juice
right
here that's a pretty cool shot yeah it's
becoming a supernatural movie now
yeah get down get
down wow getting down actually allowed
them to dodge it it worked worked it's
like what you do in a fire except what
you do with flying octopi is the
same crawl stay down yeah I would be
just
crawl
oh well
girl oh my God
okay they ate her
in WoW more of that movie do more of
that that was cool off
them what is this
sound oh do you think that's claymation
yeah these look like little models
little model yeah that's cool his eyes
oh look at the little clay model oh my
God what's growing that is neat I could
see why in his perspective he thought it
was beautiful
[Music]
yeah finally pitch black the rest of
this movie is an audible experience if
she only would have stayed down she'd be
okay she wouldn't have died you remember
the Boneyard Bard this might be that
killed every living thing on this planet
yes yes we might have drawn that
conclusion 1 hour ago ourselves as
audience
members yeah why do they do that make
that sound perhaps they're communicating
it's the way they see sonar type of site
so they just have to wait for the
eclipse to pass I
guess interesting to have Keith David
here after starring in the thing
with
yeah have you seen Doctor Who no no okay
I need to watch it though I he it's a
great show can't really uh go into the
commentary with you if you haven't seen
it you're over there on your own whoa
that looks like a dragon dinosaur a
dinosaur dragon dragonaur Dino dragon
that that works way better Dino Dragon
was the right
[Music]
move cool
alien two competing night
[Music]
visions
oh because this movie is so dark you can
get away with this visual effects really
well
right that looked kind of dumb but in
the begin ah whoa that little boy be
murdered oh whoa that looks pretty
cool all right so you just need more
bullets you see like thousands more
bullets yeah I mean he's still got that
the flamer on I would just I would flame
it light actually hurts them Ni no good
that's also Ric's weakness anything over
45 proof Burns rather well how many
bottles you got I don't know maybe 10
make a Molotov cocktail kill all those
dra Dino dragons now how long can this
last I had the impression from the model
the two planets were moving as one and
there would be a lasting Darkness oh oh
great what are yall going to do it's
going to be 20 years man oh maybe that's
why those skeletons were in there cuz
they had to weigh out the the 20e clipse
that makes a lot of sense actually how
much you weigh John around 79 kilos to
you're 79 kilos of gutless white meat
and that's why you can't think of a
better if you want to keep your your
hooa I mean sit back down sir he could
blow your head off before
you cut yeah but just even one little
prick up there buddy Dam come on now
this is like a sketch
troop they they're just all so such a
weird Ensemble of characters looks
clear
what you said clear I said it looks
clear that is true he did not speak so
definitively what what's it look like
now looks
clear that the funniest part of this
movie I feel like they've been
continually working on stuff and I don't
know what they're working on I mean now
running about 10 Paces ahead I want
light on my back but not on my eyes Okay
and check your Cuts they're building
weapons to combat them I think okay but
even before you remember we saw the same
items they're thrown around my biggest
issue is I'm not emotionally invested in
anyone yeah no no we don't care if they
really let them all die I kind of like
the captain are you ready John look
we're just wasting lot here you give
them the C in the ship and they leave
you all out there to die VN Diesel's arm
looks real nice I know man that vein
dang dude Popp oh God yeah
popping
oh cool every 10 minutes this movie
takes a break to go is Ric going to be
good or bad in the end what's it going
to
be
wait you're away from the
light get back
[Music]
here a where is he going buddy why I
people who panic and go Rogue in these
situations bug the crap out of me oh
great you killed us
[Applause]
all I mean it was bound to
happen but you got to see this awesome
Planet whoa that was cool it's great
that was
awesome do I even want to
know do I even want to know put it
together you know what's happening
that's death row up there especially
with the girl bleeding she's not cut not
her
her oh my God this movie is Progressive
well I was going to make the comment
that I was like he looks trans and the
voice like was very obviously presenting
his female and I was like oh this is
Advanced for the '90s well the movie now
gets a 10 out of 10 for me in Casey have
a notice they go off blood look this is
not not going to work cuz of period see
that's when he said cut I was like is
she actually cut or did she just start
our period That's what I'm yeah do we
have to specify that that it it's a
woman I know right my life's Su steeming
pile of meaning this [__] anyhow so I
say mush on the Cane's only a couple
hundred meters and after that it's skip
City so why don't you butch up stuff for
corking this kid let's go oh it is
because of her period during the crash
she tried to blow the whole passenger
cabin tried to kill us in our sleep shut
your mouth we are disposable wait what
blow hi hi how much do you weigh now
veric in light moves forward this guy's
the worst yeah he's giv so much screen
time
too I don't like he was on I swear to
God cuz he's famous when this movie came
out that guy yes he's was in a TV show I
think it's 90210 I can't stand him you
can't stand his character or his act
acting his character a little bit of
both okay I wanted to clear it up and
see you do the girl I'll keep fethers
off your
back hey he he don't roll that way no he
don't do that now is your time to go
Broski I'm just wondering if I don't
need a bigger piece of
B leave this let's move rck you ain't so
bad
oh wow I don't understand how this guy
puts up such a good fight against rck
well cuz he's the actual Bounty Hunter
right I think yeah but still like Ric is
is a predator like the most predominant
lethal dude because they need him to put
up a fight for the movie
Greg what
what stay in the
light come on rck you can do
it no
you one Brave before you Billy
badass the
Gage man V diesel was really cool in
this byebye now morphine guy oh don't
Rob us of this movie I want to see it we
want to see Ric do
it cool that was cool watch Ric touch
yourself Ric
whoa yes waa that was awesome that was
very cool best part of the movie killing
this guy back to the ship huh away tell
you can't see what's eating you that the
big plan where's John's which half great
response cuz you do not believe in God
does not mean God does not believe in
someone can spend half their life in a
slam I absolutely believe in God
absolutely hate the
no you are not Dominic
Tera that way it's the only way off this
rock just keep the girl between
you damn he's gone from Criminal to
Captain himself wow all
[Music]
right
oh good dodging Ric yeah also I would be
just like light lighting them up just
light him on fire do not look
go
listen listen to
[Music]
Ric why are they killing each other
because there's not enough humans to
eat it's going to be okay
[Music]
Terra
R cares about the girl it's just mushing
its head into the ground it's trying to
attack oh
wow yeah burn it throw that Molotov
cocktail right in its
mouth whoa what just happened BL
SP
cool
wa
get the blind
[Music]
spot what am I looking at I don't nobody
knows he's turning around and he's
gutting
it okay did not know who
was I didn't like that line that seemed
a little too corny except that will
probably be the quote that everyone
quotes from this movie did not know he
who he was with so where the hell's your
God
now that's a what where the hell's your
God now oh cuz clearly God doesn't love
them to put out their fire because of
the rain just tell me that the settleman
is right there you can't make
it after all that saving your ass yeah
see you later buddy hide here
now
I'm so glad that one guy's dead you
hated him I thought he really dragged
the movie down man that's what morphine
does it drags you down
man oh my God is he going to go get the
ship
himself
maybe yeah good finally let's see those
Vin Diesel muscles just move around take
your shirt off come on
buddy he's not coming back back is he oh
he is it's his character he's going to
crash through that mountain with the
[Applause]
ship oh they glow it is
beautiful they now see things the way
Ric sees what is this is this slugs like
babies oh is this like their uh
Whatchamacallit like a caterpillar like
a a worm like um cocoon cocoon like are
they cocoons with little babies in them
and the babies
glow okay smart wow how convenient that
those things are right there for them to
just put in their [__] bottles yeah
like we're probably not going to find
out what they are right that they just
decided to Glow at the last second
that's why they have the conversations
about God cuz God was gifting them with
that oh right okay and rck is their
savior leading them through the promised
land let's get your neon glow sticks and
let's
[Music]
roll you're taking too long to stare at
him centrally get in the ship and let's
go make love and then go yeah optional
there's got to be some part of you that
wants to rejoin the human race
truthfully I wouldn't know how well then
just give me more live for them I'll go
back by myself there you go please just
come in you just said a go by yourself
step
inside here I'll make it easy come
on love how taunting he is I don't
understand why he didn't just like go
back he give him a light like because it
took a lot of work to get this far and
it's too dangerous to go back why didn't
he just say that then he just seems
[Music]
mean oh she's got
PTSD oh yeah the handles they're
definitely PTSD for me me
too you listen to me I am the captain of
this ship all right there we have it you
died I
went how interesting that was the first
time I felt any bit of emotion in this
entire I agree that that that was good I
like that
part other than laughing things are
admiring and for anyone not ready for
this that is my God Mr
[Music]
CRI now let's rage movie has been
progressively better ever since we got
rid of that one guy yes I do agree think
terrible
character I kind of like his thrown away
Cowboy aspect yeah you would that's why
youve date kind of menu
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
date oh my God they're holding hands so
so sweet it's about
family
okay oh weak spot like they're all for
oh no okay cool that worked only Ric
would understand how their Vision
Works I don't understand how they
navigate how the do you see through
something like that that is
[Music]
impossible
lure it
away
smart see a
cool kill each
other
R how cruel would that have been if they
just left him hey
face no pick him up how did Ric survive
that did they just bite his
[Applause]
leg what oh who was stabbed was she
stabbed I I guess by
him oh by the thing okay oh damn a
that's
[Music]
sad well that was actually kind of sad
yeah this movie got me to care about her
in the last 10 minutes of this
movie also quite ironic how she said I
said I'd Die For them not for you and
There She
Goes is he gonna be like we have to get
the body what's he doing
PR what you doing he's got to get her
body and pay respects
right them he's going to burn them yeah
I love that hell yeah hell yeah you
can't
leave got say good
night
whoa
well done that's a pretty shot it's just
so interesting to see what vendel is now
like the Trope of vend diesel now yeah
to back then where I'm like I could take
this seriously of him yeah me too just
kind of goofy now I feel like in the
first fast and furious he was the he was
good
yeah
whoa what that's an awesome shot that
that feels
[Music]
cool all right toi David toi how was
this movie so
big I don't know maybe because there
wasn't a lot going on when this was
released in
sci-fi or just in general there wasn't a
lot going on so everyone was about it
Mary balls Miss reject Nation you know
what the funny thing is I already owned
this product before agreeing to do this
partnership I could have used my
influencer ring to get it for free or at
a discount but hey now you can get it at
a discount cuz this week we are of
course sponsored by manscape as a
married man who's always on the move I
value looking sharp while keeping things
efficient and that's where manscapes
performance package 5.0 Ultra comes in
featuring the lawn mower 5.0 and it is a
game changer the package is honestly a
perfect gift for yourself or for another
man that you might know I'll give this
to John if anyone ask I pay for it out
of my own pocket but no seriously this
is easily the best because it comes with
not one but two NextGen blade heads see
the difference it's good thing I have
two now for demonstration purposes so
you got the standard trimmer for a
perfect neat trim but this one the new
foil blade for that super smooth finish
and oh yeah it's all about safe grouping
with their Advanced Skin safe technology
plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package also
includes the weed whacker 2.0 for ear
and nose and I definitely use this
because look at me I'm a hairy guy and
the must have liquid formations the crop
Soother After Shave lotion and the crop
preserver ball deodorant say goodbye to
postet of irritation and hello freshness
and the ultimate cherry on top two free
gifts manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and
the [__] 2.0 toiletry bag again I
already have one the boxers I'm wearing
my pair right now and the bag is perfect
for all your grooming Essentials as you
can see so you're ready to elevate your
grooming game head to manscape.com and
use code reject for a cool 20% off plus
free shipping remember it's rejects for
20% off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with
manscaped thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in e-commerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors to buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
there are warwin support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team oh that
mie gave me a
headach every time I tried to take it
seriously like I was really I made a wow
2000 2000 one year after the Matrix I
made a concerted effort and then even
out of 10 on IMDb that's like no people
really like it and I that's seven I mean
I would maybe I kept trying man I would
maybe go seven out of 10 I guess to be
like there's some cool effects I love me
some Vin Diesel the monsters were very
very cool like once we got to the to the
dino dragons it was cool and especially
when he the one shot when he drinks the
the thing and then he blows it through
the the lighter and you see all them
light up like there's some definite cool
shots in here that I was like that's
awesome and so inventive uh um but yeah
I I mean I think uh like we both were
saying if anything doesn't if there's
not a heart to the story I don't like it
like we I think we felt that way with
despicable three something was some
other movie we talked about this to dri
no I know it's terrible no I was just I
was thinking about the movies the last
movies we watch that we said we didn't
like CU it didn't have as much heart in
it and this one except for at the end of
you know of her dying we did start to
care but as you said in the beginning we
didn't care really about any of them
from the top it was mainly just look at
this movie because it's sci-fi and it
looks different sure um and there's this
guy that we're all trying to figure out
whether he's good or not Ric and what is
he going to do and then random creatures
around there yeah I mean the through
line of it was not strong but um still
interesting and I liked I like the
monsters a lot espec I like the end like
if they had if they had started at the
end where they were already with the
monsters and like we got to find our
spaceship right I would have loved that
movie way more like start towards the
middle of this movie and keep going and
like maybe she dies and now we have to
still live with rck and the guy and I
don't know some other stuff I would have
really enjoyed that that would have been
a good move listen I'm just telling you
how to rewrite it toi yes go back do
what I just said maybe maybe Hawk it up
to a nine I want to see because it's
interesting because this one's like
called pitch black yeah and the sequel
is called The Chronicles of R so that's
different and then the third one is just
called called Ric so I feel like Vin
Diesel gained power and was going yes
make this more about me more about me so
much so that we're not even going to
call the third one Chronicles RCT 3
we're going to just call
it he probably obviously became the the
an executive producer by the time the
chronicles of R came out he was like
let's spin my character off from this
cuz he probably really liked playing it
um I did I did believe him the acting
didn't bug me as much as it did Greg
with that one with the other guy 90210
and the blonde girl I recognize her she
was a strong like 90s early 2000s
actress and I can't remember her name
but I really liked vend diesel this
especially when he first starts speaking
in his voiceover role which is why I was
making the joke can he please do an
audio book and vend diesel me to sleep
because it was so soothing and it's also
a voice that and a tone that I don't
hear from Vin Diesel from at all anymore
and I really like that um that's I
thought he yeah was just like relaxed
and not as corny except for that one
line but that's not his fault that was
just one line that I think I said it and
I don't remember what it was because
that's my brain that I thought was a
little corny when the thing died um but
anyhow I would I would probably with the
monsters and stuff give
it probably a seven seven out of 10 wow
that's still very kind I know it's like
I want to go six and a half but I'm like
with the monsters and how they look do
bring it back up but the stories the
story I'll give it a six it's just it's
really just the monsters and the ending
of it for me and the cool way that they
worked with light in it I did enjoy I
did enjoy how when rdick goes to kill
the guy that the music swelled in a
different way I like that well I anyway
tear it apart take it away Greg I'm not
going to tear it apart I think this
movie it has
um um a lot I think it's very derivative
of a lot of other Sci-Fi movies there's
going to be a ridic in 2024 yeah they
announced it apparently I was I found
that out okay um Ric Furia what the hell
does that mean yeah soar cly like the
the world of Ric is Big so it's got a
fan base man it's got a fan base and I
know fandoms can be very sensitive I
understand this so let's just I'm going
to kind of rate everything out scale I
think production design is my probably
the one quality of this that I enjoyed
the most I like the sets I liked um a
lot of the practicality to it and I
would give that like a a n out of 10
right there I agree with that I like the
sleaziness were cool it was really cool
Vin Diesel I thought was excellent
because it's like it's pitch black we're
just doing this one sci-fi movie now
we're gonna make an a Ric franchise you
know and I could see how taking this
character I I totally get the choice to
go let's not do a pitch black to because
it would just be a repetitive premise to
go after these
nameless creatures and and all that and
focus on Ric I understand that because
Vin Diesel is excellent in this movie he
is he is excellent uh what is that
actress's name who her character was
growing on me as we went yeah she she's
she's a great uh she's a great actor she
works all the time yeah yeah Roda
Mitchell oh that's her name yeah I just
know her from all a ton of movies she
works constant
yeah yeah she she's a she's but also did
the director did I just see that the
director and the writer of pitch black
wrote GI Jane because that's a great
script wrote gii Jane wrote The Fugitive
yeah uh he WR some great movies writer I
mean wrote Water World oh look at him
wrote terminal velocity
wow I mean wrote the arrival oh no I'm
thinking I'm thinking I was think
arrival arrival the arrivals withle
sh yes you're right um that's crazy to
me those are some
good yes yeah he's some good stuff but
you know it's ultimately a director's
movie in the end absolutely y um so I I
liked
that the
action I would put it the action I would
give like a
five the violence I would give like a
seven mhm the music I surprisingly liked
didn't comment on it at all during the
film um the music I would probably give
like an eight there was that I thought
that helped keep a pace to it yeah the
editing I'm very conflicted on yeah
that's I mean they went into some shots
where it just went in remember with the
eyeballs where
eyeball a lot of it felt
like afterthought choices in post like
you're messing with footage and let's do
this let's just do it yeah yeah a lot a
lot of it felt like that or maybe it
really CU is he also the WR he's the
writer and director of it so maybe all
of them it looks like maybe he just had
a vision and this is what happens
when when he's like I finally have
control over my screenplay here's the
weird eccentricities that really pop up
in my mind that I I can't put down in my
script here's what I really wanted to do
with the futa but then they changed it
up you know here the weird perspectives
I wanted they didn't kill a body and lay
down the skull and then transition into
where a light comes through the eye and
into a a whole view of the sun cuz
that's what happened here they made some
bold choices like the editing was so
like there was the the thing is I I I
would say the directing and
editing um was such a mixed bag for me
because as much as I
appreciated intent on style it was so
such a surface experience and the
surface of it initially I was like oh
this is going to be interesting like I
love the opening scene honestly the
crash was was gripping it was frantic uh
I really like that opening and then when
it uh
started to become the movie is what I
started to like what's happening here
like why is it so
Overexposed when they're on the land I
get it because it's the solar eclipse
when is pitch black but still like the
that did make me go like it wasn't as
great to look at yeah it it felt and it
granted it was 2,000 but then again you
know Matrix was like a year before and
that film I think still looks great
there are some parts that that look
dated but still looks great for a heavy
heavy Sci-Fi Action film this is a
different kind of movie um and but
however I I do think that there's a lot
of things in here that did feel cheap
for a universal film and like it did
feel like a b movie and I think the best
compliment you could pay is like it
feels like an above average Sci-fi
channel movie absolutely the Sci-Fi
channel went on and that's why it can
continue yeah and I could see how it can
gather that fan base because of what
it's derivative of the things that plays
on uh tropes and whatever I I think that
it it it just didn't really have a a
sense of atmosphere to me that I it
didn't evoke the the things it was
playing on didn't ultimately evoke the
emotion and mood that it needed to in
order for the things it was playing on
to ultimately work like there's no real
dread it's not
intense it's not
suspenseful there's no wonder there's
like I'm trying to think of like the
opposite emotions of those there's
there's nothing there where even even
what it's ultimately building to it is
not quite doesn't quite make you don't
quite know where it's building to yeah
yeah exactly until it it seemed like the
were it was rushing to get to where the
darkness consumes the planet
and that's about close to an hour into
the movie and they don't introduce the
eclipse thing until 5 minutes before
that happens and I think that's where
the because it the movie didn't start to
really breathe or have a real voice
around it until we entered pitch black
terrain right which just I was like
start the movie there yeah like get get
there quicker or or glue Us in that we
that's where we're leading yeah I agree
um but the hour pre uh preceding it um
no pre preluding right right preceding
righted proceed I thought proceeding
would mean proceedings yeah proceedings
after no following pre the pre
proceeding means like the yeah the pre
the
antecedent that means before okay okay
is what he's talking
about the antecedent the one hour prior
prior to the part that we started to
like just rub me the kept kept rubbing
me the wrong way and I kept trying to
give it a shot and and before I knew it
I was like Up N movie you lost me too
much cuz I'm like I've been here for an
hour I don't give a [__] about anyone
here yeah like I I don't care about
anyone here and and uh I thought they
had a it's a cool concept man you got to
survive the night it's like you got to
survive the darkness with these
nocturnal alien creatures with your one
person who can protect you it's the
criminal can you trust who can who has
nocturnal sight abilities as well and
then you got your main character it just
lacked focus and it's kind of surprising
from the person who wrote it to also
direct it who has clearly written some
great scripts before to really lack a
focus here yeah and and that was the
part of it that I find most baffling
because yeah you had a cool setup with
the characters and the creatures and the
world and conceptually there's a lot of
very interesting things here idea wise
there's a lot of interesting things and
I can't I and all when all is said and
done I can see how you can build a Ric
franchise because you have space
exploration you don't really know this
guy's backstory you don't really know
where he comes from there is things that
you can do with the character where you
can take it in a different direction
where it doesn't even have to like
mood-wise follow what this movie did
right so I would be curious to see The
Chronicles of not saying we're going to
watch it but but I would be curious only
due to the fact that uh I really liked
vinia overall that's uh for the amount
of hype I've heard around
this I I am I can't say I I overall
enjoyed I'm like a I'm like like a five
four and 5.5 out of it I mean I get it
story is not great I wasn't I'm like but
start in the middle and keep going I
liked
it yeah I mean and I love I love me some
V diesel those muscles oh man he looked
great hello yeah cuz I didn't start to
care about anybody until like the last
15 minutes until the last like when she
starts to die and she's like yes I would
die for them that was like the last five
minutes um except for when they when he
when the guy that you hate was saying go
kill the girl and I'll watch her back um
you started to kind of feel for the girl
of like when she's like oh I've hidden
you know hidden my identity away because
it'd be better to get away as a guy
would keep her safe or whatever Mulan
yeah yeah exactly uh which I like that
turn there but I feel like that even
that reveal could have been could have
meant more could have like felt it more
but I didn't it was just like oh yeah I
mean I I was literally five minutes
before she said that I was going to make
a comment saying I feel like this boy is
transed because he's presenting with a
girl's voice he does come off still as a
female very much to me so I was
wondering what the casting Choice was
and then yes it was finally revealed but
we didn't really care very much about
that turn and we should have um we did
care a little bit that she was like I
would I would uh yes I would die for
them she convinces him to go back and
then when she dies was like oh all right
that sucks there's a lot of there's one
thing when you like leave things up for
the audience to fill in the fill it in
that makes it more effective and there's
a lot of things where I can see people
justifying stuff or using their
imagination to come up with things
because like they have elements here
where you can see a heart even if it
feels cliche I would have preferred the
cliche honestly of like why is she so
attached to Ric and wanting to emulate
her whole personality off of R like I
wanted to I would want to know that zero
in on that then do something with it the
whole time I just felt like there's no
real chemistry with anyone here and some
might justify that going was because a
lot of them are strangers I'm like well
you can still feel chemistry amongst
actors in an ensemble and and uh yeah
just it it it felt like a lot of um uh
listless Mello drama I was watching like
just very un effective melod drama when
I didn't really feel the drama until
like the last few minutes of the film
where it just finally felt like real
scene workor and
not not actors in different movies
talking to each
other like the the the even them just
walking through the locations and in the
beginning there could have been side
conversations about that girl and why
she might be presenting as as another
person and why this guy is here with his
two kids and where does he come from
doesn't have to take a lot of time but
would give us something as to like maybe
why they're they're in a disagreement or
maybe why hey [__] off I'm here with my
kids because of so and because of so and
so reason which would give us a little
more of a backstory so that we cared
about them as a whole as a unit so as we
started to lose them and that wouldn't
take too much time we did we did some
just looking at stuff a lot and a lot of
repeat of like we've got to move and we
got to get this stuff together um that
yeah I just feel like if they had dug in
a little bit more with each character
when we start to lose them it it might
have made the movie raise up from a I
don't know 30% on Rotten Tomatoes to
more than that whatever it is it's
actually the oh it's 59% the highest
rated one out of out of the and
Chronicles of Ric only has 65 okay
Chronicles Chronicles Ric has second
highest audience score I don't like this
rating here because gi. Jane is at 53%
and y'all I like that movie that movie
is fun I mean give me a break
53% the oh God the fugitive is 89% yeah
he didn't he do you know who directed it
well I'm sure it's somebody great right
cuz he only wrote it red Le Scott oh
that's why there we have it it's great
see that's why I just go GI Jane is a
great film and I I didn't even know who
directed it but I knew it's good and I'm
like 53% get out of here with that um
anyway yeah I I would I would I agree
with all the the points that Greg was
rating it low for a lot of stuff but
high for Vin Diesel and the set design
very cool the monsters as I said dope
love it um yeah I mean I don't that's
all I got to say about this movie I
don't I don't know much more except I
would maybe give Chronicles reic a try I
just wouldn't be looking forward to it I
wouldn't I wouldn't sit down and go
can't wait I be like I need candy for
this movie and maybe a possible beer or
a glass of
wine there we have it I need ibuprofen
can we end the video that too I mean it
did kind of give me it's that floating
yeah the movie just like I just not
there's a lot going irritated me
he's irritated I feel all right but I'm
always walking around with a headache so
you know yeah you operate at headache
level I do that's your secret cap that's
it I mean leave us a like leave us a
comment tell us how you like it I don't
think people are going to leave likes
I'm pretty sure your most dislike leave
leave a like about us you know because
we're cool we're here we're taking a
time from our day to watch a movie with
y'all so you know be be cool be nice be
kind be awesome and you know do you got
any last words what are you looking up
he's looking up I'm going to watch the
Chronicles or Ric trailer trer and then
we'll uh and then we'll decide if we'll
watch it if it yeah but we're not going
to do that on camera no we will not but
you got some inside juice right there
you guys will see maybe we'll watch the
other one let us know if we should we
love you so much and we will see you on
the next one
bye-bye
[Music]
bye